exploremos la noción de un polinomio
parece que es una palabra complicada
pero si la dividimos podemos ver que
empieza a cobrar sentido especialmente
cuando veamos ejemplos de polinomios en
la primera parte de esta palabra tenemos
poli que proviene del griego y significa
mucho o números o en este caso muchos
novios no mío proviene del latín y
significa nombre así que podríamos decir
que polinomio significa muchos nombres
pero en el contexto matemático en
realidad se refiere a términos
vamos a hablar un poco de lo que es un
término para explicar lo que es un
polinomio y lo que no es un polinomio
les voy a dar algunos ejemplos y luego
podremos escribir algunas reglas para
ellos entonces un ejemplo de polinomio
podría ser viese x a la séptima potencia
menos 9 x al cuadrado más 15 x a la
tercera potencia más 9 este es un
polinomio otro ejemplo de polinomio es 9
a cuadrada menos 5 incluso si tengo un
número si escribo el número 6
oficialmente puede ser considerado como
un polinomio si escribo 7 al cuadrado
menos tres más pi
esto también es un polinomio estos son
ejemplos de polinomios ahora cuáles son
algunos ejemplos de lo que no son
polinomios bueno si reemplazas la
séptima potencia que tenemos aquí con
una potencia negativa
digamos que escribo 10x a la séptima
potencia negativa
en los 9 x cuadrada + 15 x a la tercera
potencia más 9 esto no sería un
polinomio tal vez estés notando una
regla de lo que no es un polinomio no
puede haber potencias negativas en las
variables de cualquiera de los términos
y ya use la palabra términos así que voy
a explicarla porque me va a ayudar a
explicar lo que es un polinomio un
polinomio es algo que se compone de una
suma de términos así por ejemplo en este
primer polinomio el primer término es
pieza x a la séptima potencia el segundo
término es menos 9 x cuadrada el
siguiente término es 15 x a la tercera
potencia y el último término podríamos
decir que es el cuarto término es 9
todos estos son términos
aquí tenemos un polinomio de 4 términos
y podrías pensar que esto que tenemos
aquí escrito en rojo también tiene
cuatro términos tenemos que poner más
reglas para definir oficialmente lo que
es un polinomio especialmente un
polinomio en una variable cada uno de
estos términos tiene un coeficiente que
es lo que multiplica la variable que
está elevada a alguna potencia así que
en el primer término el coeficiente es
10 aquí voy a escribir coeficiente
es otra palabra extravagante pero
simplemente es lo que multiplica a la
variable en este caso a la equis a la
séptima potencia el primer coeficiente
10 el siguiente coeficiente es 9
negativo el tercer coeficiente es 15 y
tenemos este cuarto término o este
cuarto número como en coeficiente porque
lo podemos reescribir de otra forma en
lugar de sólo escribir 9 podemos
escribirlo como 9 x a la potencia 0 y
así lo podemos ver más claramente como
un coeficiente entonces en general un
polinomio es la suma de un número finito
de términos los cuales tienen un
coeficiente que puedo representar por
una letra digamos a que multiplica a una
variable que está elevada a una potencia
entera no negativa esto es el
coeficiente que puede ser positivo o
negativo puede ser cualquier número real
tenemos una variable y luego el
exponente que tenemos aquí tiene que ser
un entero no negativo entero no negativo
aquí la razón por la que escribió esto
en rojo es porque esto no es un
polinomio tiene un exponente que es un
entero negativo vamos a ver otros
ejemplos de lo que no es un polinomio
podemos tomar este segundo polinomio y
cambiarlo en lugar de 9 a cuadrada voy a
escribir 9 a la potencia un medio menos
5 esto no es un polinomio porque el
exponente que tenemos aquí no es entero
es un medio y esto es lo mismo que 9 por
raíz cuadrada de a menos 5 esto no es un
polinomio o si escribimos 9 a elevada a
la potencia a menos 5 tampoco es un
polinomio porque aquí el exponente es
una variable y no es un entero no
negativo así que todos estos son
ejemplos de cosas que no son polinomios
hay otra terminología que es importante
que conozcamos polinomio es un término
general que se usa para estas
expresiones que tienen muchos términos
un número finito de términos no infinito
y que tienen esta forma pero hay una
terminología más específica cuando
tienes un solo término
o dos términos o tres términos cuando
tienes un término se llama mono mió mono
mió éste es un ejemplo de mono mió lo
podríamos escribir como 6x a la potencia
0 otro ejemplo de mono mió podría ser 10
eta a la decimoquinta potencia esto
también es un mono mió el coeficiente
podría ser digamos pi por b a la quinta
potencia cualquiera de estos ejemplos es
un mono mío ahora que es un binomio un
binomio tiene dos términos un mono mío
tiene un término mono significa 1
binomio son dos términos aquí tenemos un
binomio binomio y todos son polinomios
pero existen sus clasificaciones esto es
un binomio aquí tenemos un término y dos
términos otro ejemplo de binomio podría
ser 13 al cubo más 5 y
una vez más son dos términos que tienen
esta forma que tenemos aquí también
escucharás el término trinomio un
trinomio tiene tres términos trinomio y
este es un ejemplo este es el primer
término el segundo y el tercero ahora la
siguiente palabra que escucharás
repetidamente en el contexto de
polinomios es la noción de grado de un
polinomio escucharás a la gente decir
cuál es el grado de un polinomio o cuál
es el grado de un término dado de un
polinomio vamos a empezar con el grado
de un término dado de un polinomio vamos
a este polinomio que tenemos aquí
tenemos este primer término 10 x a la
séptima potencia el grado es la potencia
a la que está elevada a la variable así
que este es un término de séptimo grado
el segundo es un término de segundo
grado el tercer término es de tercer
grado y puedes ver este término como un
término constante que en realidad es
sólo un 9
podrías verlo así simplemente algunos
dirán que es un término constante y
algunos
llamarán el término de grado cero si
hablamos del grado del polinomio entero
entonces tenemos que ver cuál es el
término con el grado más grande ese será
el grado del polinomio entero así que en
este primer ejemplo tenemos un polinomio
de séptimo grado este de aquí es un
polinomio de segundo grado porque tiene
un término de segundo grado y es el
término de mayor grado este es de tercer
grado podemos llamarlo binomio de tercer
grado porque su término de mayor grado
es de 3º si aquí tuviéramos 5 g a la
séptima en lugar de 5 y entonces sería
un binomio de séptimo grado aquí tenemos
un mono mió de grado 15
este es un trinomio de segundo grado
otra cosa que quiero introducir aquí es
la idea de término principal y de
coeficiente principal que significa ser
principal si hablamos del término
principal es el primer término si
hablamos de coeficiente principal es el
coeficiente del primer término pero a
menudo se asocia con un polinomio que
está escrito en la forma estándar
estándar
es escribir los términos en orden de
grado empezando por el término de mayor
grado por ejemplo lo que tengo aquí
arriba no está escrito en forma estándar
porque aquí tengo el término de mayor
grado al principio pero luego aquí
debería ir el término del siguiente
grado mayor que es x a la tercera
potencia pero aquí tenemos x cuadrada
así que esto no es la forma estándar si
quiero escribir la forma estándar debo
tener 10 x a la séptima potencia que es
el término de mayor grado es de séptimo
grado y luego 15 x a la tercera potencia
que es el siguiente mayor grado luego 9
negativo por x cuadrada que es el
siguiente mayor grado y luego el término
de menor grado más 9 o más 9 x en la
potencia 0 ahora este polinomio está
escrito en la forma estándar lo escribí
en orden de grado decreciente con el
grado mayor al principio aquí está claro
que el término principal es 10x a la
séptima potencia porque es el primer
término y el coeficiente principal es el
número 10
hay mucho en este vídeo pero espero que
la noción del polinomio no sea demasiado
intimidante hasta este punto y vimos
palabras realmente útiles para que se
familiaricen con ellas en su viaje por
las matemáticas